[Music]
looking for something it would have been
impossible to guess at this moment in
1939 that humphrey bogart here playing
doctor X and this really awful horror
movie would eventually become the most
iconic actor in the history of the
cinema by this point Bogart had already
made something like 40 films most as a
contract player for Warner Brothers he
was never a leading man Warner cast him
almost exclusively as villains usually
gangsters in the gangster pictures that
flourished in the 1930s Bogart was a
constant presence in that decade but a
minor one but in the 1940s everything
changed it started with this movie high
sierra and a leading role that Bogart's
contemporary George Raft turned down
because he was tired of being typecast
as a gangster the character was Mad Dog
Roy Earle a thief who's just been let
out of jail and agrees to do one last
job high sierra is a kind of coda on the
fading gangster era and maybe because he
played so many of these characters
Bogart lends the perfect world weariness
to a story that seems faded to end in
tragedy Earl is hardened but sympathetic
or at least you get the sense that he
wants to believe there's something
sympathetic and himself even after all
he's done I Sierra was a hit and it
began a new phase in Bogart's career
sorry I got up on my hind legs boy but
you fellas trying to rope me make me
nervous Myles getting bumped off upset
me and then you birds crack and Foxy but
it's alright now now that I know what
it's all about
the same year he helped Hollywood say
goodbye to the 30s gangster picture
Bogart introduced the world to film noir
with The Maltese Falcon this was the
first of Bogart's truly iconic roles
private detective Sam Spade in John
Huston's directorial debut and it was
another part turned
by George Raft and the only chance I've
got of catching them and tying them up
and bringing them in is by staying as
far away as possible from you when the
police because you'd only come up the
works getting its own rights done am I
going too fast for you the character of
the hard-boiled wisecracking P I is
archetypal now it's thrilling to watch
Bogart create it for the movies with the
help of Houston script from the Hammett
novel and his inspired Direction bogey
is the tough guy again this time on the
other side of the law but in Sam Spade
he finds another layer of vulnerability
especially in the astonishing final
minutes never understand me but I'll try
once and give it up see Bogaerts genius
wasn't in his range as an actor he
didn't have much and as a star of the
golden era he wasn't allowed it anyway
but what Bogart lacked in variety he
made up for in depth
he went inward he took the type he was
so well known for the cynical the bruise
the world weary but still hopeful man
and minded a year after the Maltese
Falcon in 1942 he starred in Casablanca
and no one could have pulled off Rick
Blaine like Bogart Rick is a tricky part
the first half-hour of the movie calls
for him to be cold bitter and generally
unlikable traits that audit distance us
from the character yet somehow bogie
draws us in that's because he brings a
naturalism to the part that enlivens the
otherwise cliche elements of the story
I shouldn't mind that God for nobody his
cynicism isn't just cynicism it's a
shield only the topmost layer concealing
pain underneath and how does Bogart led
us into this pain through his eyes
without any action at all he's totally
transparent to the viewer so that even
the slightest twitch in his face feels
like an earthquake
with Casablanca Bogart added romantic
lead to his repertoire and he built on
it into heaven hath not the first of
four films with his future wife Lauren
Bacall Bogart wasn't the tall handsome
leading man like Cary Grant his face was
aligned with years of hard drinking yet
there's something attractive about a man
whose coolness betrays an inner
reservoir of feeling in the big sleep he
brings this romantic chemistry to
another
SiC privatized Philip Marlowe I'm a
private dick kind of case perhaps on
that too much
hello it doesn't seem too much to me
somehow and it's a testament to Bogaerts
charisma and director Howard Hawks that
a story which is famously
incomprehensible is still compulsively
watchable the part of he'll now walk and
let you have it
monkey around was Fred C Dobbs in the
Treasure of the Sierra Madre Bogart
finds another gear he plays a man
prospecting for gold with two others
they strike it rich but greed and
paranoia tear them apart
you know I don't tell him I wanna tell
him he tied me to a tree and made you
get away taking all that good yours mine
and his so they'd be looking for you and
not me well this is a new kind of role
for Bogart it's also a further
exploration of the character he's been
developing in Casablanca and his Bacall
films the vulnerability he conceals
under his tough-guy shell emerges as
love or compassion in Sierra Madre
what's inside him eventually curdles and
develops into madness and rage his eyes
burn with it go ahead go ahead brother
squeeze harder you love her and she's
deceived you you hate her patronizing
attitude she looks down on who she's
impressed with celebrities she wants to
get rid of you squeeze harder harder
squeeze harder it's wonderful to feel a
throat crush under your arm perhaps stop
it
things get even more disturbing in
Nicholas Ray's in a lonely place where
Bogart plays a washed-up boozy
screenwriter who's wrongly accused of
murder you can see how the moral
backbone of characters like Rick Blaine
Sam Spade and Philip Marlowe kept them
afloat how hope provided stability lose
that and the cynicism starts to look a
lot like sociopathy self-doubt becomes
self-hatred and that becomes a danger to
others Bogart knew perhaps from
experience how easy it is to fall on
either side of the coin whose boat is
this anyway asked you on point cuz I was
sorry for you out of Cour you loser your
brother is all wait sorry no more you
crazy sound singing skitty all made
Bogart turned in more great performances
in the 50s in movies like this one The
African Queen
but the 40s is where he became a legend
in 1957 at age 57 he died of esophageal
cancer in his life he had the fortune to
be involved with great projects and
great directors but they also had the
fortune to be involved with Humphrey
Bogart he elevated and deepened all
these movies and he took his craft
seriously there were a lot of great
actors in the golden era of Hollywood
but Bogart endures you can see his
talent but there remains something
mysterious about him something that says
unexplainable in retrospect as it was
impossible to predict
in 1939 something that's just true I
guess nothing in art survives for the
better part of a century that isn't
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching this episode was brought to you
by Squarespace if you don't know you can
use Squarespace to make beautiful
websites for anything you might need a
personal site a wedding website a site
for your business or portfolio and in
just a few clicks you can have that
website up and running their design team
has crafted templates that work on
computer browsers and on mobile
switching perfectly between the two you
can integrate your own photos and videos
with just a few clicks and you can even
link your social accounts so that you
can Auto post to Twitter and Facebook
all from within Squarespace head over to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com slash nerdwriter for 10%
off your first purchase thanks again
guys I'll see you next time